[Music]
all right let's take another call let's
go to andrew in indianapolis hey andrew
what's up man how are we doing
dr john how we doing today buddy we're
all right brother how about you
oh no not too bad not too bad
outstanding man
what's up i uh i have a almost 16 year
old son
he's uh he'd be 16 next month he's uh
autistic
and he's high functioning autistic which
means
someday he'll have to get a job have a
family
and be a productive member of society
okay um and anybody who has all
uh some with autism or a daughter with
autism knows that
even though high functioning autistic
people can definitely function in
society they definitely have some quirks
about them
sure um and he is i want to say
lazy i don't know if that's the right
word okay his iq
is off the charts he's super smart
unlimited potential
yeah but just will not get out of bed
will not get a job while not
has no desire to be a member of society
and i
just wanted to know if if you've had
people like that
if you've ever heard of such a situation
and what advice you would give them yeah
i've heard i've heard it with both
first man thanks for
i say thanks a lot on the show but
here's the thing man
there's not a lot of dads that will say
hey i'm trying my best with my son you
got some you got some ideas
so many dads just try to bury that thing
and grind it out with the way their dads
dealt with them so thanks man thanks for
being willing to ask
i'm i'll tell you what john my my dad
was a
marine was a there you go great
depression
yeah um so for me it was always just
suck it up buttercup
you know right get work done and that's
kind of how i tried to raise him and
it's not working
yeah oh man so hey well thanks for
calling man so
i do hear this a lot very common but i
hear it from
parents who've got autistic 16 year olds
and parents who have
regular 16 year olds right so
okay you're not bananas and out of the
ordinary anything like that
um how is your son with emotional
regulation do you have a good grasp on
it and here's what i'm asking that
a lot of 16 year old kids 17 18 19 even
20 21 year olds
they struggle autistic kids they
struggle with the emotional regulation
and that exhaustion doesn't look
physical it looks lazy and
that social anxiety in that build up
that i don't get these social cues
it's kind of like you if you walked into
a restaurant and everyone's speaking a
different language than you
and they're all trying to talk to you
and everyone's getting louder and more
frustrated with you
the easiest thing for you just to leave
right that's going to leave right
and so when it comes to that emotional
regulation and everybody's
like eyebrows and clicking and smiling
and not smiling and turning their heads
it just becomes a lot and dude i'm gonna
go lay down let me is
so how is he with emotional regulation i
think you just described him to a tee
okay um he he hides in his bedroom a lot
because
he doesn't do you know deal with people
very well he
uh he has the maturity of a much much
younger person
uh but yet he's he's like i said he's
extremely smart he can build a rocket
ship
someday yeah yeah yeah so we live in a
culture that
really really focuses on test scores
and test scores really really reward
intellectual like i one plus one is two
right
i know how this thing is put together
which then tags autistic kids with wow
this guy's a genius
and it does two things one it takes a
kid who may not be great at math facts
but can walk in and sell something to
you know be a day trader or can
read a room and make their way through
it and
it says that kid's dumb and he's not and
it also
says well your kid should be doing x y
and z because he can pass all these
tests and
there's the emotional regulation part
that's so heavy um
what are some ways and i'm not putting
you on the spot here i'm i'm asking you
this question because i know it'll be a
hard question to answer but it's gonna
be
a gift to the father's out there
listening to this
what are some things you've tried that
you knew
why you were trying them weren't working
and you just kept hitting the gas harder
because
you just because you're i'm out of tools
man
well for him in particular you know it's
it's a lot of times like chore list you
know i'll give him chores to do
and i know they won't be done by the
time i get home and i'll give him
consequences
for not getting him done and there's
just an excuse after excuse and
he never knows why you know it's not my
fault because of this because of this
and i keep telling him
in the real world your boss doesn't care
you know uh you're still gonna get in
trouble you're still gonna
and it just it's like talking to a brick
wall sometimes
yeah so the
frontal lobe development of a 16 year
old honestly can't process
in the real world when you're 26.
and that's the way i've done that i was
a high school basketball and track coach
i used that same line too
i used it with some of my 18 to 19 year
old college kids until i realized
they don't even know what that means
they can get it intellectually
but it doesn't wire the same way you and
i know if i don't go to work my family
doesn't eat right there's a processing
issue
um and that's not an excuse to not be a
participant in this home you will do
your chores and i'm all about that too
so here's a couple things i've seen be
highly successful
going back to educating your son on
emotional reactivity
a lot of that has to do with do i belong
and for the average 16 year old that's
the endless question and
all 16 year olds have weird teeth or
zits or they're too tall or too big or
too flat chested or too
whatever the thing is and so every 16
year old is scanning their environment
endlessly both in like both
you know with their thinking brain and
with their unconscious mind is scanning
the world do i fit in here do i belong
do i belong do i belong do i belong am i
too short am i too tall
not funny enough do i say enough bad
words do i say too many whatever
is giving him the understanding that he
belongs with you
and that he belongs at home so here's a
way to do that
this may not solve all of your problems
but here's a way to do it
you create with him you have other kids
too
i have a daughter who's 15 months older
than him yeah okay is she all in
yeah she's good she works three four
days a week she's
she's very different than him yeah okay
so i want you to get your kids
is mom live at home too uh me and
uh their mom are separated okay all
right they're divorced sorry
okay okay um and they live with you
yeah we go half and half every other
week half okay
do you and do you and mom still
communicate yes
okay like can you all work together as a
team on some on things
most of the time yes okay so you add in
how long have you all been divorced
about 10 years now
okay so you add in that additional
i don't belong anywhere now because i
belong everywhere
to an emotionally disregulated young man
and that becomes a lot does that make
sense that amplification
becomes intense and your daughter
might not be able to process it but she
can
feel it because she goes to moms and mom
does her best have a warm safe place
that she can count on and she comes to
your house and there's a warm safe place
you can count on so she can
feel that she can regulate herself there
in that environment
your son can't and so creating a safe
place for him so here's what would be
beautiful
this is a this is perfect pie in the sky
world it may not work out this way
i would love to see a scenario where you
and your ex-wife
and the two kids create a
here is the rules of our family here's
who we're gonna be we don't even live in
the same house but here's who we
are and when i say rules now we do
chores
it's deeper than that we are a family
we're talking about identity we're a
family who
respects each other we're a family who
talks with respect to one another we're
a family who
is silly we're a family who is fun we're
a family who does our best to laugh
and then we're going to create behaviors
underneath these identities and i want
your kids to participate and if ex-wife
won't participate that's great
you do this for your home i want them to
participate in who we're gonna be
and bring them in as vital members of
this family
you grew up in the house of a marine i
grew up in the house of a homicide
detective
and a swat hostage negotiator our homes
were what our homes were going to be
right and i know my dad worked i mean in
ways that i will never
fully be able to thank him for to
shift and change as he as he grew just
as a as a dad and a husband and a man
it's been incredible
but i get that home like this is what
discipline looks like and it came from a
great place there's just fewer tools in
the toolkit right
so you make sure those two kids sitting
around your table
and i've seen it done with artwork and
that's the way we do it in our house we
went to
like michael's or something like that
and we got a canvas
and we painted it at home with our
little kids here's who the deloneys are
and then we could always point back to
that
when it came to chores because it wasn't
a i told you to do these things it was
hey this house doesn't run without you
we need
you are you okay are you hanging in
there because
this place is a three this house is a
three-legged stool man and one of the
legs is just laying in the room
and what i've seen with young people is
they desperately want to know they
belong
they desperately want to know that
they're an integral part of a system
and they go to school and they're told
what to do and they go to their fast
food jobs they're told what to do and
they read social media they're just told
they're losers and the world's falling
apart around them
and they're all going to die and so they
don't belong anywhere
and so in my house at my table you're
gonna belong
you know you do and you're gonna slowly
shift your language to your son with i
know you're brilliant
how does it feel when everybody's
yelling at you in a language you don't
understand
and give him some um tools and it may be
that you all need to go sit down with an
aba
uh therapist right someone who's who's
skilled at working with autistic kids
we're gonna learn some emotional
regulation tools so that he knows how to
because you're right he's gonna have to
learn these skills
but i want him to learn these skills
tethered to
the anchor that dad says andrew belongs
because you're
mine and then from there this house
doesn't operate without you man
and then of course there's natural
consequences he's a 16 year old kid so
if he doesn't do these things hey
you opted out of participation here i
hate the fact
that you chose not to go to the movies
with us on friday i
hate the fact that you chose not to go
to driver's ed or be able to drive
i don't know i i hate it because i
wanted you with us man but you opted out
and instead of i'm punishing you for
this the results are the same
they're still gonna have consequences
but i want them to begin to internalize
these consequences not just try to
please dad
does that make sense the shift there
it's subtle but it's massive
yeah i see what you're saying definitely
so this could be a
fun exercise for you just to think man
who are we as the andrew family
like who are we man and i'll tell you as
a dad it challenged me
because we put some things like we go on
adventures and you know what my
default setting is no my default setting
is dude let's just go to bed let's just
watch a movie
in one of our family core values and my
wife slid this in i knew
she tricked me we go on adventures does
that mean
we say yes and we actually turned one of
our family core values into we say yes
so when my son comes in at eight o'clock
at night and it's a weekend and said
hey instead of going for a movie can we
go on a night walk and try to catch
turtles
yep let's do it right we're just going
to go on adventure we're going to make
memories that way
i had to change my behavior and it
became hard but then i got to model to
my kids what that looks like
and they got to participate in that one
other thing that i've seen
just with resounding success and i saw
this with college students i've talked
about on the show
um i saw a partnership with a college
theater program
and the autism center
it's a research center but it worked
with college students with autism
and listening to these young people talk
about their experiences
they were side by side with theater
actors and
they didn't know how to process emotion
they didn't know how to process
pain they got angry right or they got
tensed up they didn't know how to
process
fear they didn't know how to process
social isolation
but in a theater context they got to be
an actor and inhabit somebody else's
body
and have it a character to which they
could be taught what pain was supposed
to
look like and what they learned from
inhabiting the body of other
characters was oh this is what this
could look like in me
and so it became less personal and it
became something you practice in a
theater context and i'll never forget
it's a it's a goosebump moment
going to watch a theater performance
with
world-class collegiate actors who are
theater students
and students with autism who've been
practicing for months with this theater
troupe
it was extraordinary and then listening
to the autistic students talk about
their experiences and how it's impacted
them
so i tell you this whether it's an
instrument whether it's playing in a
group whether it's joining a choir
whether it's joining a theater troupe
there is something powerful about art
that helps teach emotional regulation it
helps teach
processing it helps teaching you may not
be able to feel this but
what is that person suggesting
what is this songwriter what is this
song communicating to you does it feel
uplifting does it feel like the lights
are out they feel like the lights are on
and it gives young people with autism or
any young
person who's struggling with emotional
regulation or spoiler alert
grown-ups too it gives them a new
language
and it's profound right so i would
suggest getting with an aba
therapist there in your community if you
haven't already and then finding
an art troupe a theater troupe letting
them know that hey this one's gonna my
son's gonna have some some special needs
here
but begin to work with him but all that
tethers back to hey young man you belong
in my house
and as a part of being in this family we
can't function without you
so here's the the tasks you've got on
your plate here's a ta i got rent
i got food i got going to work
you got garbage man and we can't do it
without you
right love the call thank you so much
andrew your stud i appreciate you man